okay it starts tonight the first
Democratic presidential debate now as a
reminder there are so many candidates
still in this thing on the Democratic
side that the first debate is being
split into two parts Part A and Part B
Part A is tonight Part B is tomorrow
Thursday evening this debate is on NBC
here are the lineups once again as a
reminder the goal to sort of split up
the frontrunners it ended up with
Elizabeth Warren as the only
front-runner on night a and all of the
other frontrunners on night B tonight
the first night it will be Elizabeth
Warren Beto O'Rourke Cory Booker Amy
Klobuchar Tulsi Gabbard who Leon Castro
Tim Ryan jay Inslee Bill DeBlasio and
John Delaney night to tomorrow night
we'll see Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
as well as Pete Budaj edge and Kamala
Harris Andrew yang is on night 2 Kirsten
Gillibrand Hickenlooper Williamson
Bennett and SWA well all on night 2 so
tonight Elizabeth Warren is the lone
frontrunner this could help her this
could hurt her we don't know we're just
going to have to wait and see on the one
hand there might be more interest
tonight than tomorrow because it is
officially the first debate night of the
2020 Democratic primary on the other
hand if you combine the polling support
of the night B candidates and assume
maybe incorrectly that the viewership
will correspond to the aggregate polling
support of the candidates on each night
then we would expect that tomorrow night
with Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders will
be the evening that gets larger
viewership more of an audience in any
case what has continued to be the
prevailing and growing narrative in the
lead-up to this first debate is Joe
Biden steady decline in the polls
combined with a surge by Bernie Sanders
and then Elizabeth Warren and most
recently both Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren if you look at the
image we have on the screen for our
video audience you will notice that Joe
Biden's lead is now the smallest it has
been since he formally announced that
he's running and meanwhile Elizabeth
Warren has had his
her slow and steady surge Bernie Sanders
just popped up several points in the
most recent polls from Emerson
University and Politico so I am excited
for the debates to start mostly to start
number one separating the wheat from the
chaff and really seeing who's going to
have even remote staying power here and
I'll be honest I look forward to the
number of candidates being reduced I
think it is great that so many people
have said I'm going to run and have put
forward varying a political platform
some more detailed some less detailed
some more focused on economic policy
some more on social policy we have seen
candidates who are both more focused
domestically and others who want to talk
more about foreign policy but in the end
this is a a list of candidates in total
that should be called I'm ready for that
to happen and I'm interested to see if
any of the sort of smaller candidates
that are certainly have strong support
from the people that like them are going
to pop in the polls as their supporters
say that they will so there's the camp
that says Andrew yang will explode after
his participation in the first debate
let's see that would be interesting I've
been interviewing Andrew yang for a year
at this point and it was one of the
earliest people talking about his
campaign there is the camp that says
Tulsi Gabbard will surge after this
debate we will soon see there are jay
inslee supporters who say he's not
well-known but he actually has the best
ideas particularly on the climate and
the country will realize this as soon as
they see him in the first debate we will
soon see as far as the frontrunners are
concerned there is a big contingent that
says as soon as Joe Biden debates
Democratic primary voters are going to
realize Joe's not progressive and he's
going to drop in the polls we will soon
see whether that is the path forward for
Joe Biden and there's also lots of
interest just in general in seeing how
the progressive wing of the Democratic
primary electorate reacts to both Warren
and Bernie finally debating now the the
only issue with that is they're debating
on separate nights Elizabeth Warren
tonight
on night a Bernie Sanders tomorrow night
in night be so in order to compare
Warren and Bernie it's going to have to
happen across sort of two debates
effectively because they will not be on
the same debate stage that being said
there is this question about will Bernie
and Warren continue to split the
majority of the progressive primary vote
or after this first debate maybe it's
going to take longer will the more
progressive contingent of the Democratic
primary electorate coalesce behind
either Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren I don't know the answer to that
but we will be live-streaming the debate
tonight and tomorrow night I will start
probably fifteen or thirty minutes
before the debate so around 8:30 p.m.
Eastern 5:30 p.m. Pacific time we'll
watch it together on our YouTube channel
and then potentially I will open up the
phone lines afterwards so very very busy
I'm actually filming a couple of
appearances on other shows and doing the
broadcast show and doing three hour live
streams today and tomorrow so I hope you
will join me because we're putting in
the time that's for sure la youtube.com
slash the David Pakman show
8:30 p.m. Eastern maybe 8:45 p.m.
Eastern tonight and I look forward to
hearing from you on Twitter as well
about what you predict will happen in
these debates I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and you can also follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
versus for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video